what is up party people what it do what
it is a common action cleopatra coming
at you live in direct Comanche from the
middle know where the center of
everywhere so what's up it's Jerry I'm
here to talk to you today give a little
first impressions on the first on put on
the purge Anarchy this is like the
seventh take of this because things just
keep busting up the chops see I'm here
to talk to you about the purge Anarchy
sequel to the pretty popular first film
the purge from last year joint
production between Platinum Dunes which
is Brad fuller and Michael Bay's company
and Blum house which is Jason Blum who
I'm a big fan of you know they do a lot
of these sort of micro-budget spook
house movies and stuff and I like their
approach and I like what they do and the
first purge is a movie that I think is
okay I like parts of it I've only seen
at the one time but it sort of struck me
like the first half felt very wooden to
me the first time a lot of the dialogue
was very stiff and and stilted and even
some of the performances kind of came
across as stiff but I thought I got a
lot better in the second half when it
became that home invasion movie and I
know a lot of people were sort of taken
aback by the fact that it was a home
invasion movie because you know you have
this very sinister idea of the world
where for 12 hours on one specific day
all crime is legal and you know I I
don't think home invasion is a bad way
to go with that but I do understand the
notion that it's not what everybody
thought it would be in stuff perhaps
what everybody hoped it would be if you
found yourself bummed or sort of
disappointed that we didn't get to
venture out into the world during the
course of the first movie
fear not or perhaps more because in the
sequel we definitely do for all intents
and purposes it seems like the sequel is
kind of what people wanted the first
movie to be all along and I get the
sense that with the first film they were
testing the waters you know they only
had about three million dollars I think
it was to make it so you know I get the
sense that they probably wanted to
see if this would work so that if it did
work they could come back and make a
sequel that had all the means to be what
they really wanted it to be and they
certainly deliver on it in this one like
I gotta say I mean I know there's some
mixed reviews going on I really like
this movie I liked a lot more than the
first one for sure
this movie improves upon the first film
in pretty much every conceivable way
this is one of those movies that no
matter how you know in your face the
actual execution is the idea is always
something that's sort of very drawing to
me so I found this movie scary partly
just because you know you imagine the
things you would need to make it
possible
aren't that far-fetched so these are
this is the kind of movie that I find
very sort of inherently jarring and sort
of upsetting so that works very
effectively as a horror movie but I can
understand why you know you might be a
little about it I really like the cast
in this especially I mean I love Frank
Grillo and I'm really happy to see him
getting work and he's great in this I
mean I'm I hope he gets more more
leading work and stuff like that he's
really good in this movie but the whole
cast is believable you don't necessarily
get to know their characters super well
just because it is one of those
situations where you're locked in with
them in this semi real time experience
so it's immediate you know you only get
to know as much as you would get to know
in a scenario like that but all the
leads are good especially the sort of
core five people we're following they're
all for the most part very natural and
believable you get the sense that these
people are actually just people and
there are certain things that they throw
into these characters that make them
feel at least to me a bit more real you
know it's everyone behaves differently
under certain stressful situations but
yeah I really like the main cast I liked
a lot of the supporting cast too
especially when you get into these these
crazy people who think it's their
god-given right to purge and all that
stuff and this movie is definitely cool
because you get a slightly more broad
view into you know who is purging who's
not purging why you know what are the
different views of different people on
this night and
you know it expands a little bit more on
the society it's definitely a sinister
movie it's got a really sinister tone
about it and there are a lot of times
where I was cringing and and and just
sort of being upset okay at least the
ideas there are some sinister
implications but for the most part
everything is handled in what feels like
the right way and this movie takes
certainly a more political approach in
this world because you have this sort of
class warfare thing going on where the
people are starting to rebel against the
idea of the purge like there's an
underground group that is basically
saying the new founding fathers are
corrupt and they're doing this to cut
down on the poor and to make more money
and all that stuff
there's some really unsettling just sort
of messed up psychology and all the
technical stuff is good I wish they
hadn't used so much CG blood but um the
it's really well shot
it feels very claustrophobic and very
paranoid the look is cool the designs
are cool just of these different you
know people out in the streets with
these masks and these things that are
going on and and in the scripting there
are some really cool surprises and some
little things you won't see coming and
those helped to keep it you know moving
along and keep it fresh and keep you
hooked on it so um I really like this
movie man I think it's a really
effective really sinister little horror
flick and I think for a lot of people
this is gonna be the movie you wish the
first one was not to take away from from
the certain merits the first one does
have because I think it does have some
but I certainly enjoyed this movie
better overall I think it's much more
consistent and I liked you know the
stories they chose to tell and the
people they chose to set it around so I
think they did a really good job with
this movie I'm happy to see that for
them so um yeah so this is a sinister
idea it's a very upsetting idea so what
did you guys think I mean if you've seen
the purge - how do you think it stacks
up to the first purge what would you
like to see the next purge movie be if
they do another one because you know
it's like we've had the claustrophobic
stuck in a house movie we've
d out in the real world movie you know
what do you think they could do next and
yeah that's it until next time I'm Jerry
the purge anarchy is the film and cheers